depuis tout petit je rêve que de ça
lors de magellan c'est le plus grand
trésor qui est toujours pas été retrouvé
5 milliards facile alors on commence
quand mais toi ça dans les règles allô
allô moi je t'entends je suis assis à
côté de toi
d'après ton frère il manquait une pièce
au passage tu connais mon frère simple
qu'est ce que tu me cache d'autres
s'imaginent pas avec qui tu es associés
ça va être plus long que ce que je
croyais
je suppose qu'on fait moi et moi et moi
et moi d'aider rectorat 10% et je
m'estime généreux
il nous faut les parachutes pourquoi
quand il saute d'un avion ça peut servir
s'est désolé
il y a cinq cents ans ma famille a
découvert un trésor avant d'être trahi
tant de morts deux pays
tél
tu es parfait
tu es toujours avec toi
jusqu'au sport
et en fait quoi du chat rien c'est pour
toi quoi tu me fais de la peine tout
seul dans ce cas partout je tarde pas ce
truc lâm